hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play
forget-me-nots enemy okay I kind of put
this on the shelf for a while I'm not
sure why but I recall some about a man
with a machete I don't know some
happened I kind of forgot about but I'm
back and I'm gonna finish it okay so I
had to restart from the scene so I need
to find the hell the thing is to plug it
out of there it is okay got it and then
you guys told me to have that big giant
idiot
huzzah Muresan whenever I start over
there is no save mechanic you have to
start over him tech points okay so
anyway you guys told me that I was a big
dumb idiot I just toss this over here
huh
and you guys told me that when I summon
wait pretty good oh oh no no no come
back here
I need to get my bear I need to get the
bear I sent it here and I Tommy you come
here you
they're going a little ride don't forget
me Annie
it wouldn't be nice to forget me
yes bear ok good again with that
squealing it sounds exactly like you
know the chase music from I amnesia ok
so if I set this over there now now all
I have to do hahaha
go follow Chris M oh okay yeah normal
Oh what is chasing me I want to know
just remember Annie What did he say you
need me Oh huh we won't you be my help
okay no you've made it this far don't
need to get sassy
I can almost hear your thoughts you
don't trust me alright now I don't
okay haha alright so I need to light
that there we go hey squeeze okay need
this but that dare take a creepy-ass
bear bring him over huh I can't bring
him inside oh there we go pull him over
there oh that's not good
okay that's that's a machine part right
there gotta somehow get up but let's
light
there's the dizzy put light that up i
dis bad boy up here that bad I can treat
it okay so you know one second
weird in there it is Boop puzzle egg
about okay so how do I get from here to
here do I put the bear up there I really
wish I would have known about the whole
bear transport mechanic earlier I mean I
know you guys told me about it but once
again I am stupid I am very very dumb
when it comes to these things like when
you have to dedicate brain cells to try
to do commentary and think and talk with
words your brain doesn't quite work that
well there okay still don't know how to
get up there I can't jump very high
I got this - I don't know wow
okay that worked all right so that is
part seven come area stupid oh yeah
stuck on that yep Cupid fear now it's
first demise won't be his last I'm
through with you okay was this story to
leave it this poor little girl this
sweet innocent thing ah fine
I was only convinced about Tom paying
something at the bear man
I was only convinced winner that stuff
another buyer
whoa hello hi lady oh you so fine
alright would think that if you weren't
here to kill me probably okay where does
this last one go I'm not saying oh wait
I see it it's up there yeah back to it I
still don't know how to get from A to B
to C there's another story see the day
the end got sent away I remember it was
very windy but nobody was flying friends
the grown-ups were all too sad to play
okay yeah that sounds normal
wait was that the little girl or was
that anything else
hang on can I jump on Howie Howie come
here
can I can I jump can I jump on you can
tie her up yeah yeah nope come here come
area stupid bear I like it up how do I
get up let's see oh look at that
okay um oh wait no I'm a big idiot
remember remark I said I was an idiot
okay hey what hey wait a minute
okay now there are children always good
son or games up there we go I don't know
maybe the angle is wrong
yeah I said I was a big idiot I don't
think of logical things like using the
damn teleporting bear ah maybe I just
don't want to use this guy here you you
you fallin die you go on the water
Rula No is there a way to unsummon him
doesn't look like it okay where's my
lantern Oh Frick a frack ah frazzle
dazzle Oh bollocks
come here tried go come here there we go
yeah maybe I'll huh gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme
put you up there there we go oh my god
that actually worked I can't believe it
hardly believe myself alright he's just
gonna have to be there alright here we
go oh hi oh remember me no I do not to
spend a lot of time together
who is this Howie I would get too close
Annie stay with me you're still playing
with Howard I see yeah Howard's my
friend you used to have a lot of friends
right I thought you and me were friends
how much my only friend Howard doesn't
play nice he doesn't want us to be
friends
he didn't want you and your mother to be
relished vieni know I don't you love me
no I don't not the way he manipulates
you Howard doesn't love you
Howard just loves Howard oh I don't
think I trust you either you secret
that's right and like the secret about
your mother
the
she's a liar she wants to tear us apart
right I can't do anything to you Annie
I just want to show you the truth lovely
this is phenomenal my power killed my
mom a bear is messed up man Oh what
you're not my friend
you don't have any friends without me
you're nothing but a crazy little girl
yeah
you're not real you can't make me do
anything anymore what is real Annie are
you more real because you are here first
or am I more real because I'm stronger
than you it was nice to be needed but
now I'm bored of you bored of sharing
this crowded party I'm not afraid of you
don't you understand
you need me Annie
it was supposed to be just you me but
now it can only be me what okay I'm
utterly confused I'm reading here it
looks like the forget-me-nots annie team
didn't like get all of what they wanted
in let's see
don't feeI I don't know I can't I can't
read them like the rest of the message
there's more up top that I can't read
but I guess that's it Wow
I mean it was really really well made
for what it was I mean so far was really
good I mean I don't know if there's the
end of the game or forever or if they're
ever gonna pick it up again but so far
as far as I can play apparently that's
all so thank you so much watching if you
missed the first two episodes go check
it out there in the place list in an
annotation you can click it or in the
description below so thank you all so
much for watching and as always I will
see you with let me check something yeah
yeah that's it okay I will see you
wait oh I can move wait a minute ha ha
lies lies is still under construction
ah ha ah Oh what is this what is all
this why couldn't I move before I was
trying hello
what nut up ba ba balls well where am I
what huh what [ __ ] Haley I don't know
ok anyway so you having ha ha I'm I'm so
confused
anyway I'm just gonna end it here if
there's any more that you guys would
like to see that there was something
there but it didn't look like that was
any more of the actual story something
about that disclaimers ah ah ok so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation more videos that I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
come on